Oh, I should have worn my Hawaiian shirt. Oh, what was I thinking? That would have gotten a laugh out of you. Damn. Mistakes, mistakes, mistakes. I'll put that clip at the beginning of the episode, so, uh... I am wearing my pineapple swim trunks, though. Welcome to ADSP the podcast episode 53 recorded on both November 13th and 23rd 2021. My name is Connor and today with my co host Bryce we catch up and chat about Bryce being in Florida and then dive into solving an algorithm leak code problem. So I was I'm in Florida visiting my parents because they hate the cold weather. My mother went to Cornell for undergrad and University of Chicago for law school, which are two of the colder options for college in the continental United States. I'm sure you as a Canadian are like, yeah, yeah,
哦，我应该穿夏威夷衬衫的。天哪，我在想什么呢？那样肯定能逗你笑。该死。失误，失误，失误。我把那段剪辑放到单集开头，所以，呃……不过我确实穿着我的菠萝泳裤。欢迎来到 ADSP 播客第 53 集，于 2021 年 11 月 13 日和 23 日录制。我是康纳，今天和我的共同主持布莱斯一起闲聊布莱斯在佛罗里达的事情，然后深入探讨一道 LeetCode 算法题。所以我现在在佛罗里达看望我的父母，因为他们讨厌寒冷的天气。我妈妈本科就读于康奈尔大学，法学院就读于芝加哥大学，这是美国本土大学中比较寒冷的两个选择。我确信你作为一个加拿大人会觉得，对，对，
that's cute. But after that, she was like, I'm done. I'm going to like move to Florida and go become the first female lawyer and like the first like female lawyer, the first like Jewish lawyer, the first like Northern lawyer at this good old boys law firm, um, in, uh, in Florida. And then she had me down here. And then for some reason she was like, let's try New England again. Um, although she had never actually lived in New England growing up, she grew up in Long Island, but let's try the tri-state area again. So then we moved up to Connecticut. And then I grew up there. And then there was one year, and she married my stepdad,
这挺可爱的。但那之后，她就想，我受够了。我要搬到佛罗里达去，去成为这个古板的律所里第一位女律师，就像第一位女律师、第一位犹太律师、第一位北方律师那样，嗯，在佛罗里达。然后她把我生在了这里。然后出于某种原因，她又想，让我们再试试新英格兰吧。嗯，虽然她长大的时候其实从来没有真正在新英格兰住过，她是在长岛长大的，但让我们再试试三州地区吧。所以我们搬到了康涅狄格州。然后我在那里长大。然后有那么一年，她和我继父结婚了，
who lived in Connecticut his whole life. And he's like, I'm never leaving Connecticut. And there was one year where there was this freak blizzard, although these days with climate change, those just happen all the time. But there was this freak blizzard and they lost power for like two weeks. And then my stepdad was like, all right, I am now ready to give Florida a try. And so now my parents live in Florida. And so I was packing to come down and visit them. And I thought I did a reasonable job of packing. Like I didn't bring any more stuff than I needed. I just had a carry-on bag, which is like a new thing for me.
他一辈子都住在康涅狄格州。他说，我绝不会离开康涅狄格。然后有那么一年，发生了一场罕见的暴风雪，虽然如今由于气候变化，这种事经常发生。但当时确实有一场罕见的暴风雪，他们断电了大约两周。然后我继父就说，好吧，我现在准备去佛罗里达试试了。所以现在我父母住在佛罗里达。于是我收拾行李来看望他们。我本以为我行李收拾得挺合理的。比如我没有带任何超出需要的东西，我只有一个随身行李包，这对我来说是个新鲜事。
Like a few years ago, I would almost always check luggage. But this time I was just like, I'll just fit it all in a carry-on bag. I don't need to bring every possible Bryce outfit. But then I get here and I'm unpacking and I realize I have two different headsets. The one that I use for recording in telecons and then my noise canceling ones, plus my ear pods, plus the microphone for recording the podcast and the boom filter and i'm like hmm i'm pretty sure that that like a fifth of my luggage was recording equipment what has happened to my life i blame connor i mean you should also blame covid. COVID created all these virtual meetings and whatnot. I should, but am I going to?
就像几年前，我几乎总是会托运行李。但这次我只是想，我把它们全塞进一个随身包里就行了。我不需要带上布莱斯的所有可能穿的衣服。但当我到了这里，在整理行李时，我发现我有两副不同的耳机。一副是我用来录音和开电话会议的，还有我的降噪耳机，加上我的 AirPods，再加上录音用的播客麦克风和防喷罩，然后我就想，嗯，我几乎可以确定我五分之一的行李都是录音设备，我的生活怎么变成这样了？我怪康纳。我是说，你也应该怪新冠。新冠造成了所有这些虚拟会议之类的东西。我应该怪，但我会吗？
You're in Florida right now. Damn. Florida. I've heard about Florida. I would love to be outside and recording so that I could make you feel jealous about the cold city that you're in but uh in the interest of audio quality i am in the most the room that i determined was best um although i do think there's a bit of an echo because they have like very high ceilings but there's nothing really i can do about that and it is inevitable even though i i warned my parents about 10 times i'm recording this
你现在在佛罗里达。该死。佛罗里达。我听说过佛罗里达。我很乐意在户外录音，这样就能让你对你所在的寒冷城市感到嫉妒，但为了音质起见，我在我选出的最好的房间里，嗯，虽然我觉得有点回音，因为他们的天花板很高，但我也无能为力。而且这是不可避免的，尽管我警告过我父母大约 10 次，我今天要录制这个
podcast today i need you to not to not come in and disturb me it is inevitable that my mother is going to burst in at some point and see whether i need water or cookies or tea or some other thing this lady is always trying to feed me she's trying to fat to feed me. She's trying to fatten me up, man. She's trying to fatten me up. Isn't that what moms are for? It is. They got to make sure you're, you know. There's something about, yeah, moms.
播客，我需要你们不要进来打扰我。但我妈还是不可避免地会在某个时刻闯进来，看看我需不需要水、饼干、茶或其他什么东西。这位女士总是想喂饱我，她想把我喂胖。她想把我喂胖，老兄。她想把我喂胖。妈妈不就是干这个的吗？是的。她们得确保你，你知道的。有些事，是的，妈妈。
And even if you're not hungry, you could be hungry shortly. And so we got to make sure that that doesn't happen. She's always planning her next meal, always planning her next meal. What are you doing for Thanksgiving? I'll be working. I mean, I'm in Canada, so the real Thanksgiving already took place in October. That is a pack of lies. I, of course, know that Connor is Canadian and was setting him up for some trolling there.
而且就算你不饿，你过一会儿也可能会饿。所以我们必须确保这种情况不会发生。她总是在计划她的下一顿饭，总是在计划她的下一顿饭。感恩节你打算怎么过？我要工作。我是说，我在加拿大，所以真正的感恩节已经在十月过过了。这简直是弥天大谎。我当然知道康纳是个加拿大人，我刚才那是给他挖坑呢。
But that's cute that you think that you have the real Thanksgiving. Also, too, let's just rewind. So you're back in Florida or you're in Florida. Technically, back in Florida is accurate because it is a little known fact that I tend to try to keep hidden from the world, although I am now saying it on our podcast. Which I believe all 7 billion people in the world do listen to our podcast. So you've definitely been outed here. I was technically speaking born in Florida.
不过你觉得你过了真正的感恩节，这挺可爱的。另外，我们倒回一下。所以你回到了佛罗里达，或者你在佛罗里达。严格来说，回到佛罗里达是准确的，因为这是一个鲜为人知的事实，我往往试图对世界隐瞒，尽管我现在正在我们的播客里说出来。我坚信世界上所有的 70 亿人都在听我们的播客。所以你在这里绝对暴露了。我严格来说
So I am technically speaking back home. And so I heard that a couple of years ago, was it a year ago, COVID no longer exists in Florida, hey? Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah. I mean, this is the free state of Florida. I was joking. I've never actually been to Miami. I've been to pretty much all the other major U.S. cities.
出生在佛罗里达。所以我严格来说是回到了家。然后我听说几年前，是一年前吗，新冠在佛罗里达不存在了，对吧？哦，对，对，对。我是说，这是佛罗里达自由州。我开玩笑的。我实际上从来没去过迈阿密。除了迈阿密，美国其他主要城市我基本上都去过。
And they're opening. When I was in Louisiana, they had this chain. This is going to be a tangent, but we're going there. They had this chain of, um, fast food restaurants called Raising Cane's and they served one thing, um, chicken fingers and like fries, but like chicken fingers and fries. And that was it. Um, and they had this sauce that was like, I would, I would, Connor, I would sell you down the river for a thing of this sauce.
它们正在开放。当我在路易斯安那州时，他们有这样一家连锁店。这要扯远了，但我们要聊到这儿。他们有一家名为 Raising Cane's 的快餐连锁店，他们只卖一样东西，嗯，鸡柳和薯条，但就像鸡柳和薯条。就是这样。嗯，他们有一种酱汁，就像是，康纳，为了那一盒酱汁，我愿意把你卖到远方。
Like it is good. It is really, really good. But they're like only in like Louisiana and like they've been spreading out like other parts of the South. I lived near the first of the stores, which is right next to the lsu campus um the the founding store and the story is that the guy who founded this restaurant chain um he was a business major and this was his you know for their final project for one of his business classes you had to come up with a business model for, you know, something. And he came up with this business model for a restaurant.
太好吃了。真的，真的很好吃。但它们只开在路易斯安那州那种地方，然后开始向南方的其他地方扩张。我住在第一家店附近，就在 LSU 校园旁边，那是他们的第一家店。故事是这样的，创立这家连锁餐厅的那家伙，他是个商科专业学生，这就是他（你知道的），为他的一门商科课程做的期末项目，你必须想出一个商业模式，你知道的，做点什么。他想出了这个餐厅的商业模式。
And basically the premise was that, you know, it was a fast food restaurant that had one thing on the menu. And that because they had one thing on the menu, you know, they had fewer ingredients that they needed to source. They could source like higher quality ingredients, you know, that there were fewer things that their staff had to learn how to make. So like they could just do one thing really, really good. And apparently the professor was like, this is like a dumb idea, like, and gave the project to C. And the guy was like, well, I'm going to go start my, you know, my very successful business. Anyways, they're opening up Raising Cane's in Miami, which is like the closest to me or a relative that I get one right now. I'm waiting for them to open one in New York, but
基本前提是，你知道的，这是一家快餐店，菜单上只有一样东西。因为他们菜单上只有一样东西，你知道的，他们需要采购的食材就更少了。他们可以采购更高质量的食材，你知道的，他们的员工需要学习制作的东西也更少。所以他们只要把一样东西做得非常非常美味就行了。显然教授当时说，这简直是个蠢主意，然后给那个项目打了个 C。那家伙就想，好吧，我要去开创我（你知道的）非常成功的业务了。无论如何，他们在迈阿密开设了 Raising Cane's，离我最近，或者说我能吃到的最近的一家店。我正等着他们在纽约开一家，不过
that'll take a few decades. But so I keep telling my mom, I'm going to come down to visit her solely so we can go drive four hours to Miami to get these chicken fingers. And so I was joking the other day with her that we're going to have to go to get to Miami while Florida is still a part of the United States. I was trying to figure out how this is going to come back to Florida and, you know, Florida. And, you know, if we've got listeners in Florida, good on you. They know. They know. we've got listeners in Florida good on you they know they know if we have listeners in Florida they get it they get it because I'm Floridian I get
那得花上几十个年头。所以我一直跟我妈说，我要专门开车去看她，这样我们就能开车四个小时去迈阿密吃这些鸡柳。所以前几天我开玩笑跟她说，我们得趁佛罗里达还是美国的一部分的时候去一趟迈阿密。我一直在琢磨这事怎么又扯回佛罗里达，你知道的，佛罗里达。而且，你知道的，如果我们有来自佛罗里达的听众，那真为你高兴。他们懂的。他们懂的。如果我们有来自佛罗里达的听众，他们懂的，他们懂的。如果我们在佛罗里达有听众，他们懂的，他们懂的，因为我是佛罗里达人，我懂
it I get it like I mean I'm not sure this is I'm not sure I mean we're not going to say anything so it's fine to mention but there's a YouTube channel that was previously called all gas no brakes and then there was like a lawsuit thing. Then they had to rebrand.
我懂。我的意思是，我不确定这是——我不确定我的意思是，我们什么都不会说，所以提一下没关系，但有一个 YouTube 频道以前叫 All Gas No Breaks，后来发生了一场诉讼官司。然后他们不得不更改品牌。
So now it's channel five news. Have you heard of either of these? No, I will send you a link. I'm not actually sure if I feel comfortable. I'll have to watch a couple of the videos and then we will link a video. Um, but it's this guy, his name's Andrew Callahan, and he records these five to like 10 minute videos where he just puts himself in the most, not awkward, but just like crazy situations and then ends up interviewing these folks that are just, let's just say, very unique and have interesting worldviews and a lot of conspiracy theory types. Like, you know, one of his most viral ones was when he got himself into like a flat earth conference and was interviewing a bunch of people. Anyways, he's got a bunch of them in Florida on Miami beach during sort of
所以现在叫“第五频道新闻”（Channel 5 News）。你听说过其中任何一个吗？没有，我发个链接给你。我其实不确定我是否觉得自在。我得看几个视频，然后我们会放一个视频链接。嗯，但这个人，他叫安德鲁·卡拉汉（Andrew Callahan），他录制了这些五到十分钟的视频，把自己置于最（不能算尴尬，但就是）疯狂的情境中，然后去采访那些（我们只能说）非常独特、有着有趣的的世界观以及很多阴谋论倾向的人。比如，你知道的，他最火的视频之一是他混进了一个地平说大会，采访了一群人。无论如何，他在佛罗里达的迈阿密海滩（在某种程度上）拍了很多这样的视频。
spring break. He's got one in like Fort Lauderdale. I have, I have myself have never been to Florida. Really? I'm not sure if I should rectify that. Most of what I see on the internet says that I shouldn't. There are cool parts of Florida. Like Tampa's kind of cool. Miami's cool.
春假期间。他在劳德代尔堡也拍过一个。我自己其实从来没去过佛罗里达。真的吗？我不确定我是不是该纠正这一点。我在互联网上看到的大部分内容都告诉我我不该去。佛罗里达有很酷的地方。比如坦帕挺酷的。迈阿密挺酷的。
Key West is kind of cool. There's other parts of Florida that are probably cool. Yeah, maybe one of these days. There were two very famous C++ committee meetings held in Jacksonville. And all the stories I could tell you both about those meetings and about the venue and the city. Yeah, it was memorable. It was memorable. Those were two of my most memorable committee meetings.
西锁岛（Key West）挺酷的。佛罗里达的其他地方可能也很酷。好吧，也许总有一天吧。杰克逊维尔曾举行过两场非常著名的 C++ 委员会会议。关于这两次会议、会场以及这座城市，我能讲好多故事。是的，令人难忘。令人难忘。那是我最难忘的两次委员会会议。
Jacksonville squared. We'll have to do a episode on that later. All right, so. You got a topic for today? Are we doing what we missed out on last time? So at this point, we've been recording for 10 minutes. We have 10 to 15 minutes of recording of the start of the leak code problem. Yeah. Do we want to do that today?
杰克逊维尔平方。我们以后得专门做一集节目。好吧，那么。你今天有什么话题吗？我们要接着上次没聊完的继续吗？所以此时此刻，我们已经录了 10 分钟。我们有 10 到 15 分钟关于 LeetCode 问题开头的录音。是的。我们今天想聊那个吗？
All right. All right. So, yeah. So then let's do the leak code problem. And then we can start our redesigning thrust sequence series. I don't know why I said sequence. All right. So probably,
好的。好的。所以，那就做 LeetCode 题目吧。然后我们可以开始我们的“重构推力序列”系列。我不知道我为什么要说序列。好吧。所以大概，
probably the way I'm going to cut this up is we'll do that little intro thing. Oh yeah. It's too bad too, because I'm flying, you're in Florida. I'm flying to Vancouver this weekend for a 10 K race where I hope to set a personal record, but folks aren't going to hear that.
我剪辑这集的方式大概是，我们会做那个小小的开场白。哦，对了。太糟糕了，因为我要去坐飞机，你在佛罗里达。我这周末要飞往温哥华参加一个 10 公里长跑比赛，希望能在那里创造个人纪录，但听众们是听不到这个了。
If that happened for like a month, because we've got part one of this part two of this, then we're recording with Eric and his dad, Eric Kneebler. That's going to be exciting. So that's probably going to be one or two more episodes. It's going to be like four episodes, but anyways.
如果这事持续了一个月左右，因为我们有这部分的上集和下集，然后我们要和埃里克以及他爸爸埃里克·克尼布勒（Eric Kneebler）一起录音。那将是非常令人兴奋的。所以那大概会是一两个额外的单集。大概会有四个单集，不过总之。
All right. So we'll cut the beginning of this Florida, Bryce in Florida plus his. Oh, I should have worn my Hawaiian shirt. Oh, I wasn't thinking. That would have gotten a laugh out of you. Damn. Don't worry.
好了。所以我们要剪掉这段佛罗里达开头的开场，布莱斯在佛罗里达加上他的。哦，我应该穿夏威夷衬衫的。哦，我刚才没想那么多。那样肯定能逗你笑。该死。别担心。
Mistakes, mistakes, mistakes. I'll put that clip at the beginning of the episode. I am wearing my pineapple swim trunks, though. All righty. I'm also wearing shorts and a T-shirt, but I'm inside. I guess you're inside too. Yes, but I am in Florida. You are in
失误，失误，失误。我把那个剪辑放到单集开头。不过我确实穿着我的菠萝泳裤。好啦。我也穿着短裤和 T 恤，但我在室内。我想你也在室内吧。是的，但我在佛罗里达。你在
Toronto. Like the ice city. Yeah, it is supposed to snow today. Although I will say, I'm going to turn that down. Toronto is becoming more and more of an attractive city to live in because Vancouver is like the other top city in canada but they had forest fires in the summer and they got flooding right now i've i've been to vancouver and i'm into toronto i
多伦多。就像冰城一样。是的，今天应该会下雪。虽然我得说，我要把那个调小点。多伦多作为一个居住城市正变得越来越有吸引力，因为温哥华是加拿大的另一个顶级城市，但他们在夏天经历了森林大火，现在又遭遇了洪水。我、我去过温哥华，我也去过多伦多，
love both cities but like i feel like toronto is like a city on a different level than vancouver really yeah interesting i mean most there's a there's a saying a lot of people from bc and vancouver call ontario on terrible because it doesn't have as it doesn't have mountains it's admittedly not as beautiful from a geography point of view so listener it's important to understand canadians very nice to non-canadians not at all nice to other canadians no we always are saying sorry it's that's like how you can tell a canadian one time here's a story one time i went down across the border because i was at a concert in windsor which is just across the border from Detroit. And so I drove through
我两个城市都很喜欢，但我觉得多伦多是一个不同于温哥华的城市。真的吗？有趣。我是说，大多数（BC省和温哥华的很多人有一个说法，他们把安大略叫作“安大草包”（On-terrible），因为它没有山。从地理角度来看，它确实不如那边美丽。所以听众朋友们，理解这一点很重要：加拿大人对非加拿大人非常友好，对其他加拿大人却一点也不友好。不，我们总是说“对不起”，这就是你如何辨认出一个加拿大人。有一次，这里有个故事，有一次我过境去了美国，因为我在温莎看一场演唱会，温莎就在底特律河对岸。所以我就开车穿过
Detroit to some like, I don't know, a couple outlet malls to do some shopping, which I don't even know why I did it because I don't really like shopping. But hey, I was told that's what you're supposed to do. Anyways, I stopped off at the subway and then ordered a subway sandwich. And at the end was just I just said, thank you. And she said, Oh, you must be from Canada. And I said, what? How did you know that? And she's like, oh, Americans don't say thank you just for making them a Subway sandwich. Oh, yeah, that's definitely true.
底特律去某个（我不知道，几个奥特莱斯购物中心）购物，我甚至不知道我为什么要这么做，因为我其实并不喜欢购物。不过嘿，别人告诉我那是你应该做的事。无论如何，我在赛百味（Subway）停下来，点了一个赛百味三明治。最后我只是说了一句“谢谢”。她说：“哦，你一定是加拿大人吧。”我说：“什么？你怎么知道的？”她说：“哦，美国人才不会仅仅因为你给他们做了个赛百味三明治就说谢谢呢。”哦，对，那绝对是真的。
I would not do that. Anyways, all right. So this is the end of this episode. We are now going to – how did I do this last time? Wait, wait, wait. We're not going to do a whole episode just about me in Florida. You've got to give people some real content. Oh, no, no, no. So the end of the episode is that we're going to cut in the 10 to 15 minutes
我才不会那样做呢。无论如何，好吧。所以这是本集的结尾。我们现在要——我上次是怎么做的来着？等等，等等，等等。我们不会只做一集关于我在佛罗里达的节目。你得给人们提供一些真正的干货。哦，不，不，不。所以本集的结尾是，我们要剪入
that we still have left from last time recording, which was the introduction of the leak code problem. This page. All right. I just have a feeling that I'm going to be put on the spot. Oh, no, no, no. At some point. There'll be one question at the end of this, but I'm not going to expect you to know any APL.
我们上次录音还剩下的那 10 到 15 分钟，也就是 LeetCode 问题的引入部分。这一页。好吧。我只是有一种预感，我待会儿会被当场点名提问。哦，不，不，不。在某个时刻。本集结束时会有一个问题，但我不会指望你知道任何 APL。
So here. The question is, actually, let's bring up the LeetCode question. I'll try and hide the title. And then I'm going to share my screen. And then first I'll just ask you. Oh, I'm not going to put you on the spot. There'll be one question at the end. Oh, let me hide the title.
所以呢。问题是，实际上，让我们把 LeetCode 的问题调出来。我试着把标题藏起来。然后我要共享我的屏幕。然后首先我会问你。哦，我不会当场考你的。最后会有一个问题。哦，让我把标题隐藏起来。
Then I'll ask you a question. A window. And we'll share this one. There we go. Here, we'll hide the bookmarks. Make it a little bit cleaner. All right. Can you read the question for the listener and answer it in C++ if you'd like?
然后我问你一个问题。一个窗口。我们把这个共享一下。好了。来，我们把书签隐藏。让画面干净一点。好吧。你能为听众读一下这道题，如果你愿意的话，用 C++ 回答它吗？
Given an integer array nums, move all the even integers at the beginning of the array followed by all the odd integers. That's actually poorly written. It should say move all the even integers to the beginning of the array and all of the odd integers to the end. So what algorithm, you can play along, listener. What algorithm in C++ can you use to solve this? Woo-hoo!
给定一个整数数组 nums，将所有偶数移到数组前面，后面跟着所有奇数。这其实写得有点烂。它应该说，把所有偶数移到数组前面，把所有奇数移到后面。那么用 C++ 中的什么算法——听众朋友们也可以一起猜——可以用来解决这个问题？呜呼！
I mean, I'm confused because it's pretty clearly partitioned. I mean, so here's the thing. Our C++ developers that are algorithm woke will be like yeah i mean that's you just explore you literally just explain what partition does i don't even need to think like about a fancy that's literally what partition does however partition doesn't exist in every language and i'm sure we have a few non-c++ devs. And even if we have like a Clojure listener right now, they're going partition. That's not what partition does. Partition and Clojure is an anamorphic algorithm
我是说，我很困惑，因为这很明显就是分区（partition）。我是说，事情是这样的，我们那些对算法了如指掌的 C++ 开发者会说，是的，我的意思是，那就是，你直接探索，你字面意思上就是在解释 partition 做的事情，我甚至不需要去想什么花哨的东西，那字面意思就是 partition 做的事情。然而 partition 并不是在每种语言中都存在，而且我确信我们有一些非 C++ 开发者。
that like splits things up. So it's closer to like a chunk than it is the partition in C++. And partition is actually one of the most overloaded in terms of what it does across programming languages. So what other languages call what C++ calls partition? I think actually just C++.
即使我们现在有一个 Clojure 听众，他们也会说 partition。那可不是 partition 做的事。Clojure 中的 partition 是一个同态算法，
Nobody else has partition? Or actually here, do you want to? Oh man, damn, I'll post this as well. Because partition is like a fairly important algorithm. I would be surprised if other languages don't have it. Wait, isn't it like your job to know what this would be in all the other languages? I mean, we're bringing up Google Translate. We're bringing it up. Wait, isn't it like your job to know what this would be in all the other languages? I mean, we're bringing up Google Translate.
它能把东西切分。所以它更像是分块（chunk），而不是 C++ 中的 partition。而且 partition 实际上是跨编程语言在功能上被重载得最厉害的算法之一。那么其他语言把 C++ 称为什么的算法叫什么呢？我想其实只有 C++ 叫 partition 吧？
We're bringing it up. We need to go to... For the listener who may have forgotten, Google Translate is Connor's thing that you tell it, hey, I want to know what this algorithm in this particular programming language is called in other programming languages. Yes, Connor has a thing for this. Of course he does. Why wouldn't he? Yeah, I mean, it's supposed to be a website at some point.
没有别人叫 partition 了吗？或者其实，你想不想？天哪，该死，我也会把这个发出去。因为 partition 算是相当重要的算法。如果其他语言没有它，我会很惊讶的。等等，知道这在所有其他语言中叫什么难道不是你的工作吗？我是说，我们要调出谷歌翻译了。我们要把它调出来。等等，知道这在所有其他语言中叫什么难道不是你的工作吗？我是说，我们要调出谷歌翻译了。
I just haven't had time to do that. My guess is that other languages call it some form of sort. Well, so I know that Haskell actually, they call it partition. But Haskell returns a pair of arrays, not just a single array. Do you know what other? It's actually a library. It's not a language. We could, but we don't. So here we are, Google Translate. So let's type in partition. So what this is here, this is color coded by implementation. And actually that's interesting. Why does oh, so yeah.
我们要把它调出来了。我们需要去……对于可能已经忘记了的听众来说，谷歌翻译是康纳的专属法宝，你告诉它，嘿，我想知道这个算法在特定编程语言中在其他编程语言里叫什么。是的，康纳对这方面很痴迷。他当然会这样。为什么不呢？是的，我是说，它在某个时候应该成为一个网站的。
All of the blue ones, C++, CUDA, and D have partition doing exactly what we do. And the purple ones I believe return well actually, let's just go to... Should we go to the Rust docs? Let's see what partition does. Creating an iterator... Consumes an iterator, creating two collections from it. So, yeah, I think purple here means that all of these languages return a pair of lists. So it is sort of the same algorithm.
我只是还没时间去做。我猜其他语言把它叫作某种形式的排序。好吧，所以我知道 Haskell 实际上，他们叫它 partition。但 Haskell 返回的是一对数组，而不仅仅是一个单一数组。你知道还有什么吗？它其实是一个库。它不是一门语言。我们可以，但我们没有。所以我们来了，谷歌翻译。所以让我们输入 partition。所以这里显示的是，这是按实现进行颜色编码的。实际上这很有趣。为什么哦，所以是的。
But then Clojure and APL, their partitions do completely different things. So if we go to the closure docs, returns a lazy sequence of lists of n items each. So yeah, it's basically chunks of. So if you give chunks of four, it'll take four elements at a time. Okay, that makes sense. And there's overloaded versions where you can also create, like,
所有蓝色的，C++、CUDA 和 D，它们的 partition 做的事情和我们完全一样。紫色的那些，我相信返回的是……好吧，其实，让我们去……我们应该去看 Rust 文档吗？来看看 partition 做什么。创建一个迭代器……消耗一个迭代器，从中创建两个集合。所以，是的，我认为这里的紫色意味着所有这些语言都返回一对列表。所以它在某种程度上是相同的算法。
where the chunk size is different than the step size, and then you got some padding and stuff. All right. So Bryce. But that, I mean, like that algorithm, the algorithm, the partition algorithm, like it must be, it must be like just a general algorithm in CS. Like there must be some term of art for it, right? Like it's some class of swarging algorithm i think it's actually talked about in uh programming pearls but i don't actually i don't remember
但 Clojure 和 APL 的 partition 做的事情完全不同。所以如果我们去看 Clojure 文档，它返回的是由每项 n 个元素的列表组成的惰性序列。所以是的，这基本上就是分块。所以如果你给它每块 4 个，它一次就会取 4 个元素。好吧，这说得通。而且还有重载版本，你还可以创建，比如，
if it had a name on it hang on hang on hang on i don't know if you've heard this story but uh when i worked for uh for hartmut uh kaiser at lsu um he gave me four books. For the first birthday that I worked there for him, he gave me his copy of Elements of Programming. And then when we moved out of the building, he gave me a hard copy of SICP, the Structure and Interpretation of Computer Programmers, which when I told you that I had a hard copy of, you got very excited because they're incredibly hard to find. They're very expensive.
块大小与步长不同，然后你还有一些填充物之类的。好吧。所以布莱斯。但那个，我的意思是，那个算法，partition 算法，它一定，它一定就像计算机科学中的一个通用算法。它一定有一些专业术语吧？就像它是某种分块算法。我想它实际上在《编程珠玑》中被讨论过，但我其实——我不记得它有没有名字了。等等，等等，等等。我不知道你有没有听说过这个故事，但……当我为 LSU 的哈特穆特·凯瑟（Hartmut Kaiser）工作时，他给了我四本书。
I mean, here, let's go. While you tell this story, I'm going to look up what the price of SICP is on Amazon. I guarantee you it's not less than 100 bucks. He gave me volumes two and three of Nef, The Art of Computer Programming, the book that Donald Newf wrote. And I was like, well, what about volume one and four? And he was like, yeah, I don't know what, I don't know how the set got broken up, but, you know, you only really need two and three. And so volume two is semi-numeric logarithms and volume three is sorting and searching.
我在那里工作的第一个生日，他送了我一本他自己的《编程元素》（Elements of Programming）。然后当我们搬出大楼时，他送了我一本精装版的 SICP，《计算机程序的构造和解释》（Structure and Interpretation of Computer Programs），当我告诉你我有一本精装版的时候，你非常兴奋，因为它们极其难找。它们非常昂贵。
And it's been a long time since I've opened this up. And so I'm going to take a look and see if I can find, if I can find partition in the index here. I'm going to give you 20 seconds to find that. And yes, you can get it in paperback for not that. I mean, $73 for a paperback text is still up there. Let's see. We got partition exchange sort, partitioning a file, partitions of a set, partitions of an integer.
我是说，来吧，我们来看看。在你讲这个故事的同时，我要在亚马逊上查一下 SICP 的价格。我敢保证它绝对不低于 100 美元。他给了我《计算机程序设计艺术》（The Art of Computer Programming，即 TAOCP）诺斯（Donald Knuth）写的这本书的第二卷和第三卷。然后我就问，第一卷和第四卷呢？他说，嗯，我不知道，我不知道这套书是怎么被拆散的，不过，你其实只需要第二卷和第三卷。所以第二卷是半数值算法，第三卷是排序和搜索。
None of those particularly sound promising but let's look at what partition exchange sort is i have i'm almost certain that's not what we're looking for and while bryce skips to that page the hardcover price used is 140 and if you want it new it's 1077 so i'm surprised you can even get it new yeah mine's a little a little uh a little beaten up um which we can look at I mean actually isn't this now that I think about it I mean I haven't really been thinking much I've just been waiting for you to find the answer. Partition is the single step within quicksort, is it not?
我已经很久没翻开过这本了。所以我要看一看，看看我能不能找到，能不能在索引里找到 partition。我给你 20 秒时间找到那个。没错，你可以买到平装版，价格没那么夸张。我是说，平装版教材 73 美元依然很高。来看看。我们有分区交换排序（partition exchange sort）、文件的分区（partitioning a file）、集合的分区、整数的分区。
Right, right. And that's the section that I'm in in the book is the quicksort section. And it's talking about how you can use this to, you know. Yeah, so this is definitely documented in... Yeah, yeah, yeah. And so I think that the origin of the term partition for what C++ calls stood partition
这些听起来都不太像是我们要找的，但让我们看看什么是分区交换排序。我几乎可以肯定那不是我们要找的。在布莱斯翻到那一页的同时，精装二手价是 140 美元，如果你想要全新的，那是 1077 美元，所以能买到全新的我都觉得很惊奇。是的，我那本有点……有点破旧了……我们可以看一下。我是说，仔细想想，这难道不是吗？我其实没怎么多想，我只是在等你自己找到答案。Partition 不就是快速排序中的单步操作吗，难道不是吗？
is probably from this 1962 CS paper, which presumably is about, you know, how you write Quicksort. All right, well, we're coming up on the hour mark here. We're going to punt this to a different episode. And stay tuned for a future episode right quick sort all right well we're coming up on the hour mark here we're gonna we're gonna punt this to a different episode and uh stay tuned for a future episode where we look your audio cut out i can't hear you your audio cut out no still can't hear you and that concludes part one of this two-part episode due to the fact that
对，对。这就是我在书里读到的那个部分，也就是快速排序部分。它正在讨论如何利用它来，你知道的。是的，所以这绝对是有据可查的……对，对，对。所以我觉得 C++ 称之为 `std::partition` 的这个术语的起源，可能就来自于这篇 1962 年的计算机科学论文，它大概是关于你如何编写快速排序的。好吧，我们马上就要到一个小时了。我们要把这个推迟到另一集节目里。敬请期待未来关于快速排序的节目。好吧，我们马上就要到一个小时了。我们要把这个推迟到另一集节目里，呃，敬请期待未来的一集节目，我们在那集里看看——你的音频断了，我听不见你说话。你的音频断了。不，还是听不见。第一部分到此结束，由于我的音频中断，请期待下周的第二部分。感谢收听，我们希望你喜欢，祝你有美好的一天！
my audio cut out stay tuned for the second part next week thanks for listening we hope you enjoyed and have a great day There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
本集暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。